we have right here in studio not only to
talk about his career and a little bit
of sports but also his book change of
seasons that's been out there for
everyone to buy your local bookstore and
or online for a few months now John
Oates
is here in studio good to see you sir
nice to be here it dulcet tones jaleco I
did like that very nice
how have your don't air you date do you
like that yes I'll uh you know I I I
don't know why I like that phrase but it
just it's something that I always rolls
off the tongue right there it's better
it's better than 8080 pop kings of pop
kings of it I by the way for just five
seconds in my life I'd love to be
described as the king of any pop right
there yeah okay I'll take is that how
you've been digging is that how you guys
have been to swell you know we had up we
had a pretty big run in the 80s but you
know to be honest with you I'm kind of
looking forward kind of guy so okay you
know those days are fantastic and that's
probably the reason we're still out
there and people are enjoying our music
seems have test stood the test of time
for the most part so but in terms of you
know I like to keep on moving forward
okay well in that regard you are you are
currently living in Tennessee correct
your easy guy he really relocated to
Nashville actually about seven or eight
years ago kind of temporarily to test
the waters and we fell in love with the
city and my wife and I we moved there at
dinner we got a house and and yeah we're
in I remember one time I was doing a
Thursday night football game on the NFL
Network for the you know then we went
there because the Titans are right there
and I remember a couple of us decided
let's go sing karaoke oh oh is right you
went to lower Broadway
well okay you know know which is let's
go sing karaoke now I I have like
Sinatra is in my register that's my
wheelhouse
John Oates okay I know I saw the picture
in the green room okay yes used well
that's that by the will shot and they
grant a great great pictures right good
I've got you know Sinatra is some
somebody who I've been idolizing for
years but any rate the reason why I
bring this up is we wound up going I was
like on a Wednesday night just a typical
middle of the week sir and we wound up
being 20th on the list to sing because
of the number of people who
just jam these places yeah and then
while we were waiting we just like an
American Idol broke out just everybody
was more talented than the next singing
at the point where you know what I'm
like maybe I shouldn't go up there but
you know enough enough courage oil got
thrown down the Gildea you know and I
got up there but it's unbelievable when
it comes to music in Nashville the bar
is set very high and on every level
I don't care whether it's karaoke cover
bands in the bars or you know all the
way up to the professional you know
level everybody is so good and one of
the things that that I love about being
in that city is it really kind of kicked
my butt to to start practicing again and
realizing it if I you know if I wanted
to be in this world because the level of
musicianship is seriously off the charts
and you know I have a great career where
I can kind of do my thing and you know
kind of I wouldn't say it's automatic
pilot but it's definitely something I'm
so used to it's easy but I got there and
I said man I want it I want to stretch
out a little bit and meeting these
incredible musicians who have become
friends with and being embraced by the
musical community there really it really
said man I can I can still keep moving
forward and I love that any any i'm
flying to nashville it also was the note
of the largest number of people who came
on the plane with guitars oh yes I've
ever seen everybody that qatari we knew
we were heading to Music City the only
thing the only thing it's probably on
the on the way down as the cowboy hat
the cowboy has been replaced by the
baseball hat okay and then if you got
hair you don't need that either well
that's another that is that's a yes it's
a long story for me John Oates here on
the Rich Eisen show but now it's hockey
hats in - oh where did you get into the
Predators you know I've been there for a
number of years and I kept hearing you
know you got to go to a Preds game you
got to go to Princeton and to be honest
with you I really would have not been a
hockey fan my whole life so when the
playoffs came of course the madness
swept over me and a good friend of mine
had tickets and he got got us styled so
I said okay you know what if I'm going
to go in see my first hockey game why
not the playoffs and I have to say the
energy in that room and I played the
Bridgestone Arena yeah you know
musically yes uh but the energy in that
room for a hockey game was off the
charts way to jump through the
television screen
in credit you if it jumps through the
television screen you can imagine what
it's actually like and you know you've
got the country singers you know I think
the night I was there Tommy Shaw from
Styx was playing you know they have a
whole band set up and they've great
guest stars and you know a lot of the
big country stars are there you know
Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman or big or
big fans and you know of course Carrie
Underwood with her husband but you know
so you see all these people and the
energy is really incredible so don't I
enjoyed it did you throw a catfish on
the ice John I didn't so a cap it but I
bought a smash yet did you oh yeah I got
my smash doctor smash absolutely what
about the Titans what about following
out of the tent well when I first moved
to to Nashville we lived in a condo for
a little bit because we weren't 100%
sure we wanted to stay in the city and
then marcus mariota moved into our
building
come on no I'm not kidding well of
course he moved into the penthouse you
know I wasn't it oh I was going to lowly
closet you know on the seventh floor big
he signed a good rookie contrary he did
it yeah but turned out I ran into him in
the lobby and then I ran in from some
restaurants and you know local
restaurants great guys so so polite nice
and I dug him because I liked him at
Argonne you know I watched him in Oregon
I always thought it was great and all of
a sudden here here again the energy of
the titans is on the way up and they
look like they've drafted well and so so
now you know I'm pretty I guess I guess
I'm kind of pickled man I'm just like
I'll just root for whatever team in the
city I'm living a little bit for the
time being because I've moved all around
the country what about Philadelphia
where obviously you went to school where
you met Darryl hall I mean that's been a
long time ago I moved out of
Philadelphia in 1971 believe it or not
but still Adelphia kind of like rocky if
you if you've ever lived there you're
from Philadelphia so and but it was it's
been a big part of our music roots and
our influences but uh I went to Temple
University of course when I went there I
wasn't involved in any sports at all I
actually went there on a wrestling
scholarship believe it or not hold on a
second so yeah I know John Oates
Renaissance man man Renaissance man yeah
I don't want to call you a King of Pop
because when you arrest like working
Michael Jackson owns that that title you
know we don't need to go so you went to
Temple honor on a wrestling I did I
wrestled my freshman year at Temple I
wrestled one
Hatchin one and I quit I I got tired of
losing weight I could not lose weight
anymore I wrestled all through high
school
um and and I started you know I was in a
band and I wanted to play and I was
staying up late at night and doing other
things that people were doing in 70s and
the wrestling had a you know that was it
what's the craziest thing you did to
lose weight oh well back in you know
back in those days when I went to high
school you know they didn't they didn't
have people watching over your diet and
making sure yeah we we wore rubber suits
and spit you know went into like with
with sweat suits on top of rubber suits
sitting in a steam room and you know
starving ourselves I mean you know they
didn't care about kids in those days
right when and when did you realize that
you had a gift for music John what was
that well that's that's my whole life
really I started singing when I was a
little kid I was you know I don't know
why it just happened I made a record in
Coney Island believe it or not in one of
those little recording booths when I was
a little kid I think I sang here comes
Peter Cottontail at four years old went
back a few years later and sang an Elvis
song which I actually still have and
what you still have it I well you know
you'd make a record in these little
booths in the amusement park yeah and it
would spit it out and you keep it I
still have that little vinyl record that
I made in length 1956 when was the last
time you listened to that Oh quite a
while ago okay yeah I think so every
honest in the John Oates household yeah
we have a record I had a little bit of
vinyl but I'm not a vinyl fanatic okay
but my new album that I'm going to put
out in 18 which I might as well plug
while I'm here go for it huh
it's called Arkansas and I'm going to
put that out on vinyl fact I just we
were just talking to a Jack White about
he just built a new vinyl pressing plant
in Detroit which is really cool because
they're revitalizing downtown Detroit
and there's such a demand for vinyl that
so I'm going to go up there and press
the record Jack White's press the record
I bet you never thought you'd be saying
that again not I get you right right but
you know what vinyl is cool and the
music business needs a whatever
encouragement it can get at this point
okay so I'd like to take a break and
talk some more about your beginnings
yeah and and
the days of you and Daryl all getting
together if you'll indulge and then also
get a little bit more into that time I
guess you would be down in the lobby and
there's marcus mariota visiting the same
male character that's that's interesting
stuff John Oates is here on the Rich
Eisen show again the book change of
seasons is out there for to uh to read
and enjoy John Oates career and we'll
get a little bit more into that book
when we come back Leonard fournette of
the Jacksonville Jaguars also still to
come here on this edition of the Rich
Eisen show change of seasons is the book
John Oates is the author and he is
sitting here on the Rich Eisen show
studio your kisses are mindless from
back in the day right here on the Rich
Eisen show with John Oates so let's talk
about some of these hits that you and
Daryl Hall created all right okay who is
the rich girl is there a specific rich
girl that's out there Japanese story was
actually a guy okay there was a guy who
was friends with Daryl's girlfriend in
college and he was a trust fund kid I
read tons of money and no responsibility
and he he was all he went off the deep
end and he was a complete you know kind
of wacko he were in relying on his old
man's money he was relying on his own
man and Daryl actually just sat down and
just has a joke said you're rich guy and
he gone too far you know and obviously
you know he realized the immediately it
wasn't going to be rich guy and just
changed it to rich girl so it's
literally that that's where the song
came from so it was about it was about a
guy who shall remain nameless yeah okay
he's long since gone I met who was them
who was the maneater was there a
specific maneater out there John it it
started out I was in a I used to hang
out in a restaurant called Mary Lou's in
the village back in those days a lot of
musicians actors models and you know
groovy eighties types would kind of hang
out there and one night this gal came in
and she was a model she was absolutely
devastatingly beautiful but she had the
Fallas mouth on any human being I've
ever heard and her
her her great beauty and her disgusting
vocabulary kind of like went you know my
I went like she would just chew you up
and spit you out
I was kind of excited and scared all at
the same time and I went back and I
started writing a little [ __ ] you know
sure she'll chew you up and spit you out
and that evolved into the song and then
I came up with this kind of reggae
version of it and then I played it for
Daryl he said let's do a more of a
Motown feel and that's and we just
finished it up but the reality is when
we started writing the lyrics we wrote
it about New York City
if the man-eater is actually the city of
New York in the 80s with that you know
that wolf of Wall Street mentality that
more is better you know the guy who dies
with the most toys wins so it's really
kind of a yeah you know without being
too highbrow was a metaphor for New York
City so who was the inspiration for kiss
on on your list with Louis basic was
there any specific well I don't know
where that inspiration came from because
the idea came from a gal named Janet
Allen who was Daryl's girlfriend's
sister and she was a up-and-coming
songwriter and she actually came up with
that title she just came up with that
yeah and then Darryl worked on it with
her John Oates here on the Rich Eisen
show is there one song that you think is
your proudest that you that you just
throw out there that you're voting proud
of jaya that's that's always a tough
question i always go back to she's gone
because it was a song that really put us
on the map was a song where the world
heard heard about us for the first time
and to this day i mean whether i'm
playing by myself or i play with darryl
we play that song every night we've been
playing it since 1972 and it sounds just
as good now as it did and i guess that's
where you you know that's where you put
the bar as a songwriter you know if you
can write a song that will stand the
test of time and i think that's that's
really what's about and you you you
write about so many moments in your
career and your book change of seasons
of when did you how did you meet daryl
hall how did how did the two of you
finally just get together well it was
kind of unusual circumstance we i had a
band this was in the late 60s in
philadelphia and he had a group and we
had both made singles independently of
each other they were being played on
philadelphia R&B radio but vhat and WDAS
and so i had known about him he had
known about me
the city really the music scene in
Philly was very small in those days and
we both got invited to do a record hop
which like a teenage dance in a pretty
pretty tough neighborhood in West
Philadelphia
we were waiting backstage to go and
lip-sync our songs and a gang fight
broke out
and there was like shots and screaming
and yelling we went down the service
elevator and that's exactly how we met
and then we were like oh well I go to
Temple University and circumstances
happened after that two of the guys in
my band got drafted in the Vietnam I
joined Darryl's group as a backup guitar
player that group fell apart he and I
started hanging out and making music and
then the rest was was history was sort
of well now that's sort of I think on
John was there ever a moment though
where you talked about having Oates and
Paul well he's older than me so I always
give I'd like to be deferential okay so
that was basically the it was age yet
old that age before you go there's age
before you go good I like and you know
what I'm gonna add that into my rep but
will you use that I will I don't roof
much I will use that I don't require
dulcet tones and age before you get
dulcet tones of John Oates age or ego I
will remember all these here on the Rich
Eisen show
is there anybody whose music now you
appreciate I'm a fan of a lot of greats
I mean I'm very much into like the
Americana roots music scene you know
Alabama Shakes Mumford & Son you know My
Morning Jacket guys like that you know
and I like I like a lot of that stuff
but in terms of pop and I love Bruno
Mars I think Bruno Mars is doing it man
he is can I say badass on you may so
there's been far worse said into that
Park I thought in front of you he's
badass I love him I love what he's doing
and I think it's you know I like Justin
Timberlake there's a there's a lot of
great people that yeah Bruno arm did be
Super Bowl in New Jersey the New York
New Jersey Super Bowl which it was real
fortunate for him and the NFL it was a
unseasonally balmy 60-degree day on that
first Sunday in February but him signing
up for it he had no idea he could have
been out there in a 10-degree member
prince in the rain Prince in the rain
that was
- husband and I'll never forget this
John prince in the rain being there and
seeing it yeah well okay then I'm good
yeah yeah I just want it to be at every
Super Bowl and I've been fortunate to
interview every Super Bowl act for the
NFL Network okay it with a comforter or
worse
well no no well it's been it's been
interesting okay um because for various
reasons Mick Jagger actually broke down
Super Bowl 40 an NFL on-air analyst he
knew everything about the Steelers in
the Seahawks he's a smart guy he broke
it down turned 74 yesterday yeah by the
way but anyway the reason I bring this
up is that Prince was the first was one
of the first people to not only say no
interviews but he didn't do a press
conference either he didn't hold a press
conference he he held a concert yeah for
the media members we did yes and it was
on from instead of instead of getting up
there and answering all these questions
from the murders of the media display
that's it i'ma let my music speak for
myself one of the Great's of all time no
doubt about it what's the gig that you
you want to do if you could choose one
stake on them I travel I travel all the
time and I swear young people is a Tom
gig yeah where do you want to go my
house pretty much I yeah you know I've
been on the road since I've been 18
that's a long time and I still love
playing believe me I do but when I went
when if I'm you know left to my own
devices I love staying on my love
writing songs I like going in the studio
with and creating new stuff right that's
that's what keeps him going
so what then what is the best venue you
have played personally or you with daryl
hall well you know delighted together
the big ones always stand out because
you know the whatever you know Live Aid
the first Live Aid which we played with
Mick Jagger which we headlined and we
had Tina Turner and Mick came out and
that's when he ripped her skirt off and
it was pretty pretty incredible we had
Eddie Kendrick and David Ruffin from the
temptations sang with us and we kind of
reprised our Apollo Theater show playing
the Apollo Theater back in the 80s with
them was an amazing moment
you know all those moments when you play
Madison Square Garden for the first time
when you go to London for the first time
all those things stand out in your mind
but honest honestly I love playing a
little venue in Nashville you know I'll
go to the station in and play on a
Monday night
with some friends and to me that it's
just as good and so um the current tour
would Tears for Fears
last couple of dates had to be canceled
due to circumstances beyond your control
are there any plans on we we are going
to go and reschedule that show as soon
as possible and it was you know in Los
Angeles yes we we actually had to cancel
San Jose and the two dates at the
Staples Center so we're looking for
dates in mid-september hopefully we can
find some lots of names before
basketball's day before the Lakers and
Clippers takeover exactly so but the
tour was going so well and was a great
summer love the Tears for Fears and just
love the whole package it was really
great and we can't forget the Los
Angeles Kings player as well don't
forget your hockey fan now okay thanks
to the Preds thanks for money didn't
know no I don't I don't I don't want
hockey fans coming after you in your
hometown because then people have
totally found it the athlete that has
come up to you to say I love your music
that you were really you know impress
whether a ball and you mentioned Dan
Marino in the television only segment
the radio audience now well back in you
know back in the 80s there were a lot of
every time we'd go to a football town
football players would always come out I
became really good friends with Dwight
Hicks then was a cornerback for the 49
Shore and and then meet me and Joe
Greene and those guys from the Steelers
used to come around
Carl eller and it was cool I mean we
still go to parties with those guys I
felt very safe by the way dr. Carl eller
and Mean Joe green would definitely hey
it was make you safe yeah I never had to
worry about much in those days but um it
was a you know so they were the glory
days of just hanging out with you know
but it's very similar to what you know
the young young pop artists of today the
contemporary artists today they hang out
with you know the modern sports stars
you know it's all that it's always that
intersection between music and sports
and Johnny Mack you've you've come
across his path well uh yeah I've known
John for long
time I was a very avid tennis player and
I lived very close to Mats Wilander in
Connecticut for a while and Matz was
also a musician and when they would do
the US Open Matz would always have after
they resurfaced the courts at the US
Tennis Center Matz would have his
personal court resurfaced with the exact
same material okay so they could
practice on the same surface so he would
always have a bunch of guys come over to
the house and he'd call me up and say
hey I got a bunch of the guys chameleons
want to come over and I go yeah of
course you know being a tennis fan so
I'd show up with my little tennis
racquet and so one day I was I went over
to Max's house and they were all having
lunch and hanging out in the house and
he said max out on the court he's you
know he's John McEnroe yeah he's
stretching out he said watch you go out
and hit with him I went okay so I went
out there and I'd known John but you
know and he said yeah let's hit so so
I'm out there there's nobody around it's
just me and John McEnroe and we're
hitting and I'm going this is freaking
amazing I said I wish some wood could
see this yeah and but the coolest part
was and I was an okay club player you
know I could hit the ball but you know
when you compare yourself to a pro it's
a whole other thing
but he's going through this hole McEnroe
thing so he's hitting these shots and if
he hit a shot he didn't like he'd be
like wrong you know I'm going this can't
be really happening and that's that's a
level of competitor that he was you know
and it was really cool it was really
cool I like I said I wish someone could
have seen it but nobody did no but it's
a great story so don't lie it's real it
is not a lie it is not fake news and if
when so there are two John's out there
Oates was the one to say to McEnroe you
can't be serious kind of stuff you would
flip it out yeah bad job he yelled at me
one time we were playing a video game
somewhere in New York City at somebody's
house one time when video games just
came out there and he did the same thing
of the video game he was that he
actually yelled at me and said you're
not trying man because you're not trying
it was like weird but but you know what
that's that's what a competitive spirits
all about John thanks for coming in here
Congrats on your book change of seasons
we're all big fans of your your work and
your immunity for many years so we're
we're really appreciative thanks for
coming appreciate it you bet
Rich Eisen show we
days at noon eastern on radio stations
across the country and audience if you
like some of that get some more of that
on the Rich Eisen shell app follow all
the information you see right here on
the Rich Eisen show